من ساعات في كنيسه المرعشلي في القاهره
تشييع جثمان الاعلامي المصري الكبير مفيد
فوزي واللي رحل صباح اليوم عن 89 عام
[موسيقى]
على نفسي
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
المحاور ورائد الصحافه تلفزيونيه اثنين من
قائمه من الالقاب والاوصاف اللي على مدار
السنين اطلقت على مفيد فوزي الى انعرف
باسلوب مختلف وعملوا الصحفي والحوار
لتجاوز السياسه والاجتماع للفن والثقافه
والادب وغيرها وعلى مدار عشرات السنين قدم
مفيد فوزي حوارات كثيره انحفرت في ذاكره
الملايين اللي او الى جانب برنامج الشهير
ايضا حديث المدينه اللي استمر على شاشه
التلفزيون المصري اكثر من 20 سنه مميزوا
في كل ما قدم اسلوب مختلف واسئله اصبحت زي
اللازمه او يعني العلامه المسجله مثل
السؤال
انه تسمح لي اسئله بالطبع من وقت الاعلان
عن وفاته اسم الراحل ترند وعلى كل من
الصوت والنجوم ومشاهير وساسه
وترحموا عليه
وينضم الينا الاعلامي المصري تامر امين
اهلا فيك معانا تامر واول شيخ خليني ابتدي
بتعازينا الحاره انا عارفه انها مش بس
خساره مهنيه هي ايضا خساره شخصيه بالنسبه
لك
اهلا ساره تحياتي لك والاستاذه المشاهدين
في كل مكان هي خساره
انسانيه الى شئت التعبير الاستاذ مفيد كان
قيمه انسانيه كبيره جدا جدا جدا بكل البشر
وكان مؤثرا وكان حاضرا وكان ملئما لنا
جميعا وعلى المستوى الانساني
كبيره جدا من العلاقه الشخصيه الوطيده
اللي كانت طردتني به مش بس استاذي ومعلمي
وملهمي
استاذ توفيق كان يعني ولد الثاني بعد ما
فقدت والدي منذ سنوات رحمته الله عليه
الاستاذ مفيد حل محله وكان والدي في
الحياه وكان والدي في الاعلام
وكمان جماعتنا زمان المهنيه اخر سنتين لما
كنت بشارك حضرتك في الفقره الاسبوعيه اللي
بيعملها برنامج كلام مفيد
ورحيل ورحيل ساترك اثر كبير جدا جدا فيا
وفي كل المحيطين الاعلام العربي
اخر مداخله لويا تامر كانت معاك ايضا في
البرنامج وكان حتى فيها ضحك وكان عنده
لازال روح متفائله وكان بتكلم منه حيخضع
لعمليه وما الى ذلك وحتى انت يعني كنت
بتحاول انك تقول له انه يلا ان شاء الله
تقوم وترجع لنا هل تواصلتم بعد هذه
المكالمه اللي كانت على الشاشه
اللي كان على الشاشه ده كان من اجل العمل
وكنت باحاول اطمئن الجماهير والمشاهدين
على صحه الاستاذ مفيد اللي كان داخل يعمل
عمليه في القنوات المراريه وزي ما انت قلت
كان في منتهى المرح وفي منتهى الطاقه
والتفاؤل لدرجه حتى ان هو صاحب
الفسحه الجميله اللي حتى المرض اللي بيجيء
لي له علاقه بالقنوات والاعلام
رحمه الله عليه ثم بعد المداخله طبعا ده
انا كنت باتواصل معه ومع حنان صديقتي
واختي يعني همم
اه كريمه الاستاذ مفيد
كنت باتواصل معها انا وكريم برنامج طول
الوقت عشان اطمن عليه والاخبار الحقيقه ان
هو كان يعني في حاله مستقره لكن الاعمار
بيد الله
طيب تامر يعني الاعلاميين كثار جدا بس
قليل النجوم وقليل اللي بيتركه
خاصه فيهم مفيد فوزي ليش عمل هذه الحاله
كيف قدر يعملها ايش ميزه
لا يعني
ايش ميزو دي ممكن نكتب فيها مجلدات
الاستاذ مفيد
الاستاذ مفيد اهم اهم ميزه في انه كان طول
الوقت مفيد فوزي لم يكن شخص اخر ولم يبحث
عن التقليد ولم يبحث عن محاوله يعني
الاجاده لمساحات شخوص اخرى
كان صعب ايضا انه يتقلد يعني هو كان ما
يجلد وما كان احد يقدر
يجلدوا على الاجاده الكامله في الصحافه
وفي الكتابه وكان فارس القلم وفارس الكلمه
بلا منازع وجمع الاجابه كمان المتالقه في
العمل الاعلامي التليفزيوني عايز اقول لك
ان كل البرامج اللي احنا بنعملها دلوقت
انا وزملائي عمرو اديب ولميس كل برامج
اليوتيوب كلها خرجت من رحم من البرنامج
اللي علمنا يعني ايه برامج اهتمامات الناس
وهو البرنامج بيقشر حديث المدينه الاستمر
في تقديمه اكثر من 20 سنه على شاشه تسبيرو
فالحقيقه الاستاذ مفيد كان كان متفرد وكان
صادق وكان جريء وكان لا يؤمن بشيء الا
يفعله وكان معندوش فكره التردد ابدا وكان
دايما صاحب
الاسئله اللي انا بسميها الرصاصات
التلفزيونيه والصحفيه كان سباك باجراء
الحوارات اللي شملت كل نجوم العالم في
السياسه والفن والادب لدرجه حتى انه في
اخر لقاء تلفزيوني بيننا في البرنامج عندي
انا قلت له الواحد يا استاذ مفيد يعني ما
يتمناش سي في التليفزيون
ظاهر حتى في مشاركه وايضا في برنامج انت
تحدثت الان عن الرصاصات الاسئله اللي هي
زي الرصاصات
فعلا هو اا جريء يقول اسمح لي اسالك
وبعدين يضرب قنبله يعني هل حكى لك شيء مره
عن مثلا كواليس واحده من المقابلات او
واحده من المشاكل اللي صارت له بسبب مثلا
سؤال من هذه الاسئله
طيب
طيب احنا فقدنا الاتصال مع تامر بس خلينا
مشاهدينا نحنا هناخذ وقفه مع نقطه من بحر
ارشيف الراحل مفيد فوزي معظم حياته يسال
الاسم بالكامل فؤاد زكي المهندس العمر
العمر
6 سبتمبر 27
الحاله الاجتماعيه
بهذا
البراع الانسان الخرافي يعني عمرك
لماذا طلقت
للاعلامي المصري انا كنت بسالك على هذه
الرصاصات واحنا عرضنا مقطع من هذه
الرصاصات يعني لما نقول لعمرو دياب يعني
لماذا طلقت يعني عمر دياب ما كان عنده رد
في البدايه عشان يستوعب الا انه عيد
السؤال يعني هو في حاله ظهور فهل حكى لك
شيء عن كواليس مشاكل او طرائف من هذه
الرصاصات
اللي انا تشرفت ان هو همم جمال ان فيها
على مدار سنتين في برنامج اخر النهار على
شاشه النهار كان الهدف الاساسي منها لما
فكرنا فيها كانت همم حديث الذكريات ان هو
يجيء ويحكي لي على كل المواقف وكل
الكواليس وكل الاسرار والانفرادات اللي هو
عملها على مدار تاريخه وبعد كده لما انا
استاذ الفقره تبقى ثابته ودائمه مساء كل
اربعاء طورناها بقى للاسم اللي كان موجود
لحد الاسبوع اللي فاتوره فقره الكلام مفيد
وكان هو اللي بيختار الموضوع وهو اللي
بيختار ال- ال- العناوين اللي بنعيشها
وكانت بتتحول الى دردشه مفتوحه بيني وبينه
علشان طول الوقت يبقى في حاله التفاعل على
الاسم البرنامج
ياما ياما حكى لي طبعا على مواقف هو تعرض
فيها للاحراج بسبب سخونه وصراحه اسئلته
وطول الوقت كنت بتعلم منه ازاي يسال وازاي
يخرج المعلومه كان واحد من الارقام اللي
انا بحب اطلق عليه جدا فكره الباحث عن
الحقيقه لانه من اكثر الناس اللي استطاعت
انها تخرج لنا من سجن ضيوفه واستطاع اللي
هو ببراءه شديده يجبرهم على التكلم بمنتهى
الاريحيه
كان بعض الناس يقولوا على اسلوبه ان في
شيء من الاستفزاز
ولا راي الحقيقه انه دي كانت من احد
مزاياه النادره
الاعلامي عليه ان يكون همم يعني
وتملك شويه القدره على الاستفزاز الضيوف
حتى يستطيع ان يخرج ما بداخلهم لانه
المذيع اللين الحريري لا مجله وسط الغابات
اللي احنا بنعيش فيها دلوقتي
احطها من الحكم اللي تعلمناه اليوم او
اللي لازم نوثقها اليوم سريعا تعمل اذا
قلت لك اكثر شيء اتعلمته منه تعتز فيه
تعلمته
كثير بس اللي انا اتعلمته انه همم
قل قل ما تقتنع انه الصواب حتى لو انت
عارف انك هتتهالي وتنتقد الاستاذ مفيد
بيقول كلام قبل الهوا يقول لي انا الكلام
اللي انا هاقوله ده هيجيب لي وجع دماغ
الناس مش هيعجبها قوي بس انا هاقوله عشان
انا عارف ان فيه مصلحه وانا الحقيقه اعتقد
ان انا ماشي على هذا الضرب همم لا يهمك
رضا الناس بقدر ما يهمك رضا الرب
[موسيقى]
ذكرياتكم مع الراحل كان معنا الاعلامي
المصري تامر
[موسيقى]